[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tb 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
triathlon trois sportifs licenciés à
poissy s'envoleront pour les jo de tokyo
cassante beaugrand léonie ap rio et
dorian conax ont été officiellement
retenu nous aurons avec nous dans cette
émission le président du club
vigouroux ainsi que la triathlète les
oliverio tennis le tournoi de roland
garros a débuté ce dimanche 3 heavy noix
sont engagés dans cette édition 2021
dont saint germanois arthur rinderknecht
le président du comité des yvelines
francis eveillard décryptage décryptera
cette actualité avec nous automobile un
rallye 100% féminin ils sont pour son
élective électrique est parti ce
dimanche depuis versailles
coup de projecteur sur cette édition
parrainée par l'humoriste franck dubosc
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres on
va parler football l'équipe de france
est arrivée mercredi dernier au centre
d'entraînement de clairefontaine dans le
sud des yvelines les 26 joueurs choisis
par le sélectionneur didier deschamps
ont préparé l'euro de football qui se
déroulera du 11 juin au 11 juillet dans
11 pays européens
les amateurs des bleus ont scruté avec
attention l'arrivée de l'attaquant karim
benzema après 2058 jours sans
convocation
le groupe sera au complet cette semaine
dans cet écrin yvelinois le staff attend
notamment les joueurs qui ont disputé
les finales européennes et surtout les
vainqueurs de la ligue des champions
ngolo quand et kurt zouma et olivier
giroud ouf
un mot de voile à présent l'avait quitté
sur le podium du dernier un vendée globe
en janvier dernier louis burton est de
retour le skipper originaire de
rambouillet a mis à l'eau son tout
nouveau bateau bureau vallée dans le
port de saint malo racheter auprès de
l'occitane en provence juste après la
course l'imoca totalement repeints et
est totalement adaptée aux besoins du
navigateur à l'intérieur comme à
l'extérieur louis burton espère
maintenant pouvoir à l'apprivoiser avant
le prochain vendée globe pour cela il
participe notamment cette semaine à the
ocean drive europe un premier challenge
qui se déroule entre lorient et gêne il
est pour l'instant 3e dans la catégorie
imoca
on va maintenant parler à de triathlon
la fédération française a dévoilé le nom
des triathlètes qui participeront aux jo
de tokyo cet été parmi eux figurent
trois sportifs de poissy cassante
beaugrand léonie perriot et dorian
connexes pour vous parler de cette très
bonne nouvelle pour le club yvelinois
nous avons avec nous via écran interposé
le président philippe gros ainsi que
l'une des athlètes sélectionnés pour
tokyo léonie ap rio bonsoir
alors je crois qu'elle est aussi
problème du côté de léonie j'espère
qu'on va le régler d'ici quelques
instants
en tout cas c'est une très grande
nouvelle pour vous j'imagine au club de
poissy philippot par écouter on a déjà
eu des plus mauvaises nouvelles que
celle là effectivement et avoir trois
athlètes qui vont représenter la france
et qui sortent
de notre sérail bon c'est bien
évidemment vous vous en doutez une
grande fierté c'est c'est une
reconnaissance du travail effectué et de
l'investissement qui a été celui des
entraîneurs des dirigeants du club de
tous nos partenaires qui nous ont fait
confiance pour accompagner des athlètes
comme léonie dans un projet sportif de
haut niveau parce que bon léonie et est
au club depuis depuis la catégorie des
jeunes depuis cadettes minimes cadettes
cigogne noire est bonne et ben on va
prendre prendre une gamine qui qui
commence la pratique du triathlon est
d'avoir au départ d'une épreuve de jeux
olympiques
vous vous imaginez que bon ça ne laisse
pas insensible
donc bon c'est c'est une grande
reconnaissance pour le club dans tous
les gens qui travaillent pour le club
mais surtout pour pour tous les
partenaires qui nous font confiance et
qui nous suivent dans le temps dans
notre projet sportif éducatif
d'accompagnement des sportifs de haut
niveau bon c'est une grande fierté aussi
pour pour le département pour la région
pour la communauté urbaine et bien
évidemment pour la ville de poissy qui
est notre premier partenaire depuis
maintenant plus de 35 ans donc il faut
du temps mais on y arrive et un as de
belles reconnaissances
voilà inutile de vous dire que en attend
avec impatience cette échéance et en
espérant que ça sera ça serait une
consécration
bon sur deux épreuves différentes
puisqu'il y aura une épreuve en ligne
traditionnels de triathlon qui va se
dérouler à tokyo au mois de juillet dans
des conditions climatiques qui sont très
particulières
léonie entendra peut-être tout à l'heure
avec des conditions de chaleur et
d'humidité extrêmement important tous
les efforts demandés sur les sites
fortement l'organisme et je pense que
sur une sur la course en ligne
comme c'est souvent d'ailleurs le jeux
olympiques aux jeux olympiques c'est
souvent la course d'un jour
on est susceptible d'avoir des
défaillances rdc petit bard deschamps on
va écouter léonie et léonie est ce que
vous nous entendez déjà
très bien alors j'imagine que c'est une
grande fierté pour vous d'aller à ces
jeux de tokyo cet été bah oui non
carrément bascule il va très bien résumé
je suis vraiment très fier et c'est vrai
que ben c'est un honneur de représenter
possible à ce qu'on ait fait pas je les
côtoie depuis
depuis je pense 2010 par là donc c'est
vraiment bas c'était le but et on a
réussi
ce seront vos premiers jeux olympiques
cassante beaugrand et dorian koninck
sont est déjà présent à rio mais pas
vous comment vous l'appréhendez
justement qu'elle appréhende bas
forcément j'ai une petite pression parce
qu'on est fait je connais pas je connais
pas vraiment la compétition
surtout que ça va être même des
conditions assez particulières mais je
vais mais je me préparais pour du coup
je bois je serai prête mais j'ai aucun
doute là dessus et j'ai hâte d'y être
philippe drouet ce que ça peut jouer ou
pas que ça soit ses premiers jeux
olympiques justement à léonie froid ce
sont ses premiers jeux olympiques mais
elle a une expérience internationale qui
lui a valu d'ailleurs sa sélection
puisque en matière de régularité de
progression l etat l a prouvé qu'il
avait le niveau international qui lui
permettait d'avoir à dos a pour
participer à une épreuve comme celle des
jeux olympiques
donc bon on l'a gagné en maturité
s'entraîne elle s'entraîne au pôle
france à montpellier
très régulièrement avec l'équipe de
france avec ses coéquipières et je pense
que bon ils sont dans une bonne
dynamique de travail et qui sont
vraiment très bien préparée avec des
séances interne pour reproduire un peu
les conditions les conditions de chaleur
et humidité qui vont trouver qui
montrerait tokyo ce jour là quoi non je
pense qu'elle est prête ils sont prêts
et maintenant les aléas d'une
compétition sur une journée dans des
conditions météo particulières ça peut
réserver des surprises sur un effort de
longue durée
par contre sur le relais est un effort
plus court là j'avoue je suis beaucoup
plus confiant parce qu'on sera moins à
la merci d'une défaillance physique
le seul obstacle pourrait être une chute
incident mécanique
un aléa de ce style alors il ya trois
yvelinois sur cinq sélectionnés c'est
c'est un bon ratio on peut le dire pour
poissy est ce qu'on peut dire que poissy
le meilleur club de france
leoni bah ouais non non si c'est
carrément on peut le dire quand on est
champion de france depuis de multiples
de multiples années pardon donc oui
voyez clairement on peut le dire il ya
une très bonne formation
et voilà donc on va dire mais ça a
remercié le club met ainsi que
département et c'est au début j'espère
alors léonie vous êtes yvelinoise vous
êtes originaire des yvelines de vélizy
villacoublay vous avez été formé à
versailles lors de vos premières années
est ce que ça fait d'autant plus plaisir
de représenter votre club un club des
yvelines
bah oui non non carrément bien sûr c'est
vrai que j'avais toujours mike hurd va
de rester dans le département c'est ce
que j'ai fait parce que je suis fier de
mon département est faible et j'ai vécu
sur vélizy après les vécus mais sur
josas mais j'ai toujours été licenciés
dans des clubs dans le département donc
c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir de
montrer les couleurs du 78 elle montrer
les couleurs de poissy jusqu'au japon
est ce que ça vous fait plaisir aussi
philippe pour le coup d'avoir une
yvelinoise à 100% dans votre équipe
donc savez quand on a un produit qui
sort qui sortent de là de la plus
première comme on dit c'est c'est
l'accession au niveau en étant passé par
toutes les filières de formation donc
c'est une très belle reconnaissance pour
tous les éducateurs qui ont travaillé
avec léonie depuis son plus jeune âge et
qui ont participé à sa progression
je parlais tout à l'heure de
l'encadrement de l'équipe de france est
une finalité en matière de préparation
mais à tous ceux qui ont su détecter
quand sur encourager quand su faire
progresser mais honni pour qu'elles
arrivent comme les autres niveaux qu
elle aussi aujourd'hui c'est pas
important
léonie qu'elles sont ou aux objectifs
justement sur ces jeux olympiques 2000
21 bat déjà donc sur l'épreuve
individuelle qu'on aura lieu le 27
juillet ça sera vraiment faim je dois
dire que je me fixe pas d'objectif parce
qu'on ait fait ça va être une course
très particulière mais la chaleur mais
c'est la course que j'aime
du coup je me fixe vraiment pas
d'objectif bas nos limites et je serai
vraiment le mieux possible
si je peux aller décrocher la meilleure
place sur ce format là c'est un top 5
donc si je peux aller décrocher un top 5
voire mieux
ça serait génial par fait et après me
concernant le relier le rôle est pardon
qu'a lieu le 31 juillet mais le jour de
mon anniversaire en plus bas là on est
clairement favori on veut clairement le
la médaille d'or alors ce sont vous
prouvez géo on l'a dit tout à l'heure
vous avez 26 ans est ce que c'est le
moment pour performer m'a bien sûr oui
bahia après oui bah je me sens prête
quand il n'y a pas de raison on ne sait
pas là je dois m'arrêter et en tout cas
mais je vais tout faire pour être pour
être vraiment prête le jour j oui est ce
que vous allez vous mettre dans votre
bulle ou plutôt profiter de l'événement
dans quel état d'esprit vous allez être
sûr sur cet événement non non je vais
vraiment rester focus sur mes courses
parce que c'est clairement l'objectif je
suis pas là pour pour profiter des jeux
c'est vraiment là pour performer et on
profitera après un libre vous confirmez
elle va être sérieusement tout au tout
les jo
alors je vais vous faire une confidence
même si elle n'avait pas envie d'être
sérieuse elle sera condamnée et sérieuse
parce que les conditions qui vont être
mises en place au niveau de
l'organisation sur la gestion des
grippes descharles déplacements des
groupes ça va être un peu à l'image de
ce qu'elle a vécu il ya quinze jours à
yokohama où les bons de sortie ils
étaient d'une heure par jour et dans des
conditions très particulières et avec un
confinement dans chaque chambre
avec 6 qui m'a été rapporté est vrai je
dirais un vigile sur chaque palier de
des tâches d'hôtel pour veiller à ce que
à ce que chaque sportif respectent des
consignes d'hygiène et de sécurité
vraiment très très draconiennes dans la
question à léonie qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter pour ces prochaines
semaines et surtout pour ces jo bats
pour les prochaines semaines de faire
des bons entraînements de me sentir bien
et ne pas ne pas me blesser ou déchus
trois premiers petits aléas
je touche du bois et après concernant
les jeux va faire du mieux possible et
ramener une médaille est la plus belle
c'est possible
merci à tous les deux d'être intervenu
dans cette émission suivra évidemment
ces trois pistes yake cassandre léonie
et dorian sur ces jeux olympiques cet
été et on espère évidemment des
médailles je vous rappelle les dates des
jeux de tokyo ils se dérouleront du 23
juillet au 8 août
merci à tous les deux directions à
présent un versailles coup d'envoi de la
première édition de nature l aventure un
projet pour sensibiliser au respect de
l'environnement programme réalise 100 %
féminin en voiture électrique pour
conduire de façon économe avec trek et
orientations dimanche 30 mai les binômes
ont pris le bus devant l'hôtel de ville
versailles et pour rejoindre le point de
départ de la course en haute savoie
un reportage de justin ghazi naturel
aventure le premier challenge électro
féminin au monde et yvelinois un rally
d'une semaine à lyon véhicules
électriques et trekking ou encore
orientation dimanche les équipes ont
quitté versailles pour se lancer
officiellement dans la course ce lundi
31 mai le départ a été donné à annemasse
en haute-savoie un évènement 100%
féminin le projet est vraiment en faveur
de l'environnement en faveur de la
mobilité électrique est vraiment on a
souhaité dire qu'avec une voiture
électrique on est capable de faire un
rallye et parce qu'on est des femmes on
est également capable de s'orienter
objectif conduire de façon économe
franck dubosc parrain de cette première
édition soutient la cause depuis le
départ fictif à versailles
l'artiste s'est allié à ce projet en
faveur de l'environnement
allié à presque chaque événement quelque
chose écologique s'est montré à tout le
monde que bach c'est important et puis
qu'on peut le faire surtout qu'on peut
le faire et que c'est assez facile de le
faire
dallier l'écologie à n'importe quel
événement voilà donc je trouve que c'est
c'est une
c'est une belle cause je trouve que
l'écologie surtout lancement c'est une
belle cause parce qu'elle doit nous
réunir tout ce n est pas l ai pas
clivante
douze équipes ont décidé de relever le
défi chaque binôme américaine de
formation pour apprendre à s'orienter en
challenge des connectés sans gps ni
téléphone mais avec carte et boussole
ce sera une expérience enrichissante de
d'orientation puisque que ce soit en
voiture ou à pied lors des treks on a
deux cartes et boussoles et puis
l'intérêt de ce projet c'est que tout ce
qu'on tout l'argent qu'on a qu'on a pu
lever pour ce but ce projet sera
reversée à des associations en faveur de
l'environnement
objectif pour les équipes parcourir 1000
km en une semaine
retour prévu le vendredi 4 juin à evian
les bains en golf antoine ros meneur n'a
pas réussi son premier tournoi du grand
chelem le golfeur de la bouillie à
versailles n'a pas passé le cut lors de
l' us fidji et 2020 en caroline du sud
les viennois de 28 ans rendue deux carte
de 79 et 71 et rate la qualification
pour le week-end pour un seul coup
antoine ros nord annoncé sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'il était encore difficile
pour lui d'avoir raté le cut pour si peu
mais qu'il espérait revenir plus fort
son prochain tournoi sur le circuit
américain est programmé cette semaine au
mémorial tournament dans l'ohio
il tentera cette fois de se qualifier
pour le week end
on continue à part du tennis roland
garros a débuté ce dimanche du côté de
la porte d'auteuil plusieurs événements
participent à ce rendez vous arthur
rinderknecht dans le tableau 1
chloé paquet chez les dames et antoine
ghibaudo chez les juniors pour faire un
tour d'horizon de ses joueurs et du
tennis dans les a's yvelines nous avons
avec nous par visio le président du
comité et des yvelines de tennis des
yvelines
francis eveillard bonsoir bonsoir
alors on va tout de suite parlé du match
tant attendu entre le saint germanois
arthur une énorme tâche et marines
ilitch le croate dans le top 50 mondial
il joue en ce moment il perd 7 6 6 1 2
sets à 0
francis eveillard à une réaction à une
réaction c'est que arthur j'ai suivi sur
vos mobiles
le premier set c'était très très
accroché puisque arthur a eu quand même
trois balles de set contre bien sûr sur
service de cilic
mais malheureusement il n'a pas pu les
concrétiser et je pense qu'après lui un
petit coup de peut-être deux
défaillance minimes et soul deuxième set
où l'appel ci leach a pu se détacher
très vite dans ce deuxième set
bien sûr le troisième set ce salaire à
nouveau accroché donc rien n'est perdu
et toujours espoir qu arthur puisse
redresser la barre et puis continuer à
progresser mais je pense qu'il a fait
quand même un très très bon parcours
notamment au tournoi international de
lyon où il a quand même été jusqu'à en
quarts délais des battues en quarts de
finale et je pense que c'est toujours
sur cette progression importante et
qu'il a depuis le la saison 2020 et la
saison 2021
il est mené même trois sets 3 jeux à 1
dans le troisième set
et c'est bien sûr à l'heure on
l'enregistré mission donc et à 18h47
exactement est-ce que arthur et notre
neige fait aujourd'hui partie des
meilleurs français
oui quand on regarde est-ce qu'on peut
le ciel à al harra c'est-à-dire au
classement des points obtenus depuis la
saison il est le deuxième meilleur
français dans ce classement
donc c'est un des meilleurs français en
terme de progression
et puis en termes de régularité là sur
ses derniers résultats
est ce qu'être surpris comment parce que
vous êtes sur un pays tout puisque
arthur il était quand même qu'ils ont
entraîné de longues années au comité il
a été également champion universitaire
avec le lycée de villepreux et entraîner
encore une fois par le comité et après
c'est surtout son séjour aux états unis
où il est parti après son baccalauréat
ou là elle a pu participer aux
compétitions
disons universités américaines où elle
le niveau est quand même très très élevé
je crois qu'il est revenu après avec
bâtissons une force mentale et puis en
technique bien sûr il avait continué à
progresser mais je suis pas du tout
surpris de sa progression et je manque
je pense qu'il peut encore continuer à
progresser alors ces dernières semaines
il avait dénoncé le classement le
gel du classement atp est ce que ça
montre un petit peu le tempérament du
garçon il avait dénoncé du coup ce gel
du classement qui l'empêché d'aller un
petit peu plus haut au classement et du
coup d'avoir des meilleurs tournois et
plus de gains forcément est exactement
puisqu'il espérer en pouvant justement
continuer à aller sur un serveur de
tournoi rentrer dans le top 100 est ce
qu'il a il avait était pas très loin
puisque eeel et 117e au classement mais
ce gel des classements l'empêcher sa
progression vers le top 100 si on a été
très très belle performance en si peu de
temps ils aient eu raison de le faire à
votre avis comment il a eu raison de le
faire de dénoncer ce gel du classement
non je pense que bon il n'était pas le
seul et dépenser ce gel c'est vrai que
c'était handicapant notamment pour lui
puisque encore une fois comme je les dis
c'était au niveau des points obtenus
c'était le meilleur français donc ce gel
du classement ben c'est vrai que la
handicaper pour encore une fois rentré
dans le top 100 alors chez les dames il
ya également la versaillaise chloé
paquet je vous demain contre la
polonaise lynette
alors que pensez-vous de chloé paquet
bachelot et c de même c'est une une
fille que nous avons justement entraîné
au comité depuis sur de longues années
et qui continue sur le circuit
professionnel adéquat de sang de 148 au
classement wta et donc elle a 26 ans de
san 48e joueuse mondiale
je précise oui tout à fait et donc est
elle continue à être sur le circuit à
avoir des résultats réguliers maintenant
faut qu'elle passe le cap au dessus et
et ça c'est quand même difficile puisque
la concurrence est quand même très rude
sur cette catégorie
deux jeunes filles ou c'est pareil
maintenant il ya des tas de gens qui
arrivent sur sur le circuit et on peut
pas dire d'ailleurs qui est hiérarchie
peut-être comme chez les messieurs
l'arrière chip obligé d'une année sur
l'autre et donc chloé faut continuer à
progresser peut-être à monter encore
plusieurs crans dans dans ce dans ce
classement on va voir ce qu'elle va
faire là contre le néo zélandaise mais
bon j'ai aussi confiance en elle une
fille qui est très très accrocheuse et
qui bon qu'ils aiment ça et qui est bon
qui vit son pénis quoi enfin il ya ce
jeune antoine ghibaudo la pépite 15 ans
seulement il va participer à roland
garros chez les ch et les jeunes chez
les juniors qu'est ce que vous en pensez
cesser votre pépites ou la paix comme ça
golf hôtel que je valais c'est sûr quand
ouanna a eu a eu 16 ans justement en
janvier dernier faut le rappeler qu
antoine était quand même trois casses et
359 au classement chez les juniors je
rappelle que les juniors c 17 18 ans
donc il était pratiquement avec 3 2 ans
ou même à un an maintenant davance et
entre septembre 2020 et février 2021
il est plein il est passé quand même de
classement 10 359 au classement 69
junior donc c'est vraiment il est dans
les cinq meilleurs mondiaux de sa
catégorie d'âge intersaison et puis là
il est classé comme il n'a pas pu
participer due à la crise encore une
fois du coc vide un certain nombre de
tournois il est je crois 94e au
classement classement junior mais
antoine c'est vraiment le comme vous
dites notre tpiy et je pense qu'il a un
avenir
s'il continue sur cette progression il
est là dans une phase au niveau de
sondage qui est vraiment une phase
importante au niveau du physique il est
grand il est encore un petit peu le
frêle je pense que il a un travail
physique avant important
à fournir pour maintenant éclore
vraiment au plus haut qu au niveau mais
je toute confiance dans dans sa
progression
merci à vous francis eveillard merci
d'être intervenu dans cette émission on
suivra avec attention les futures
performances de nos yvelinoise sur les
courts dont léa prochaines années en
cyclisme c'était dans les cartons depuis
plusieurs mois le vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines va accueillir
les meilleurs pistards du monde à
l'occasion d'une nouvelle compétition
cycliste certes cette dernière baptisée
traque champion's league aura pour
objectif de booster les audiences de
cette discipline au reportage c'est
désormais officiel 20 novembre prochain
le vélodrome national de saint quentin
en yvelines va accueillir les meilleurs
pistards de la planète à l'occasion de
la ligue des champions piste ici est
toute nouvelle compétition répartis sur
six soirées pendant six semaines avec 72
coureurs on aura la crème de la crème
parce qu'en fait les coureurs doivent
participent au championnat du monde
d'abord ils ont rendu être qualifié pour
le championnat du monde et aux
championnats du monde
seuls les meilleurs en fait se seront
qualifiés pour aller dans cette ligue
des champions
trente six hommes 36 femmes c'est la
parité c'est super quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant avec les meilleurs
athlètes du monde
cette nouvelle compétition a également
pour objectif de booster les audiences
du cyclisme sur piste à travers le monde
on est sur un format très court 2 heures
on vient d'abord au vélodrome comme on
va venir voir une une pièce de théâtre
comment on va venir à voir un match de
foot comment on va venir voir autre
chose on va venir voir un spectacle un
spectacle avec des athlètes y aura aussi
de la musique du show mais comme ça avec
des fromages très très court très
compact une nouvelle formule qui a
convaincu le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le site
accueillera la deuxième manche
le but promouvoir la structure en vue
des jeux olympiques de 2024
la notoriété de la visibilité mais
également cela va permettre de l'ouvrir
à nouveau au public on va retrouver la
passion le fait que ce vélodrome sera
complet comme il a été pour les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste il ya maintenant quelques années
en gros c'est le dynamisme la visibilité
pour que la fête soit encore plus
réussie le vélodrome national de saint
quentin en yvelines espèrent pouvoir
accueillir le maximum de public dans ses
gradins si la situation sanitaire le
permet en novembre
au chapitre solidarité comme chaque
année depuis 28 ans l'association sos
gazelle a organisé ce mercredi 19 mai
son traditionnel tiebreak le rendez vous
programmé sur une journée au golf de
hersant a permis à plusieurs sportifs et
célébrités de s'affronter sur une partie
de golf parmi eux l'ancien joueur du psg
amara simba alors handballeurs olivier
girault l'acteur lucien jean baptiste
en parallèle des jeunes des ivy non plus
pratiquer des activités sportives la
journée s'est terminée par une vente aux
enchères le maillot signé par kilian est
mbappé ou un autre dédicacé par zinedine
zidane ont trouvé preneur les fonds
récoltés serviront à financer à complexe
en faveur des enfants défavorisés au
sénégal et on termine par une dernière
information le doyen des cyclistes
robert un marchand est décédé le 22 mai
à l'âge de 109 ans ces dernières années
il avait été établi plusieurs records de
l'heure dans différentes catégories
en janvier 2010 est à 105 ans il avait
notamment parcouru 22 547 km sur la
piste du vélodrome vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
il était revenu également pour un
entraînement non-officiel en 2018 on
écoute justement ce qu'il avait déclaré
à notre micro même âge est bon on peut
faire encore quelque chose mais ne faut
pas se laisser aller
les jours on vous et soyez là vos
fauteuils et bien vous bougez plus vous
êtes foutus taïga mouais je continue
tous les jours tous les choses a fait un
peu de culture physique
bien entendu le saluer le plus en plus
dur j'ai attrapé la maladie ou savez ce
que c'est la ballade amiez ou que ça
allait pas à bord est un très beau
message c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv
[Musique]